[Música]
faltou que o mundo perde esse negócio de
vocês deixar de existir uma empresa que
você trabalha acabou que o mundo perde
essa é uma pergunta que todo
empreendedor deveria ser capaz de
responder mas infelizmente nós somos
direcionados a refletir sobre perguntas
assim é refletir sobre o por que quando
é criança lembram se lembra quando eu
perguntava por que que diziam porque sim
só que porque assim não há resposta
porque sim
não pode ser a resposta para o
empreendedor basicamente existem dois
tipos de empresas
o primeiro é um grupo de empresas que
deixa o mundo melhor quando nasci
do outro lado está o grupo de empresas
que deixa o mundo melhor quando deixa de
existir e aqui eu queria tratar desse
primeiro grupo o grupo de empresas que
leva a humanidade que deixa o mundo
melhor quando ele passa a existir só que
para isso a gente precisa olhar pra
dentro
a gente não está acostumado a olhar pra
dentro a gente sabe o que a gente faz a
gente sabe como a gente faz a gente não
se pergunta por que que a gente faz
como diria está em mãos inec como diria
o grande mário sérgio cortella porque
fazemos o que fazemos porque levantamos
todos os dias qual o sentido com
significado com a alma eu digo a vocês
empresas têm que ser mais tartarugas sim
tartarugas não vim falar de biologia e
vim falar de empreendedorismo empresas
precisam olhar para dentro que uma
tartaruga faz quando ela tem uma ameaça
quando ela tem um caminho a seguir
qual é o primeiro comportamento dela se
recolher olhar pra dentro é porque é lá
que estão as respostas é dentro dela que
ela consegue se conectar com essência
dela e assim seguir
e esse é o convite que eu faço para os
empreendedores para que eles sejam
tartarugas também antes de olhar para as
oportunidades externas olharem para as
inquietações internas que eu quero mudar
como negócio qual é o valor que eu quero
levar para a humanidade a partir daquilo
que eu estou oferecendo como um negócio
na verdade a gente tá cheio de
cardumes no mercado seguindo um fluxo
sabendo o que faz sabendo como faz mas
sem consciência por trás das nossas
ações e assim a gente constrói um
mercado vazio
lembra quando vocês eram crianças que
perguntavam para vocês que vocês querem
ser quando crescer eu lembro muito bem
sempre me perguntavam isso e acho que a
gente faz com que nossas crianças que
você quer ser quando crescer
elas falam advogado bombeiro médico
jogador de futebol ea gente constrói
adultos pensando no que vou fazer o que
eu preciso fazer para ter de vencer na
vida né isso que dizem pra gente mas eu
falo para vocês
a gente precisa vencer na vida eu digo
vencer na vida
vencer na vida e eu digo pra vocês
imaginem se a gente mudasse essa
pergunta para as crianças ea gente
perguntar se eu vejo o que você quer ser
quando crescer a gente perguntar se o
que se quer mudar quando crescer
qual é a sua causa qual é o impacto que
você quer deixar qual é o legado que
você quer deixar como você quer ser
lembrada
sim ser super-herói crianças nascem com
essa essência que a gente possa manter
isso
o mesmo acontece com empreendedores que
vivem à grande crise hoje a maior crise
que vivemos não é a crise econômica é a
crise de significado é a crise de
sentido é o vazio existencial e na
verdade a segunda feira fica mais ou
menos assim porque trabalhar possa ser
um trabalho trabalhar não é uma
expressão da alma não expressão daquilo
que você acredita mais é um trabalho eo
que a gente quer através dessa proposta
é mostrar que trabalhar não precisa ser
um trabalho trabalhar pode ser um prazer
e domingo de noite pode ser lindo que
amanhã de manhã segunda feira
mas para isso é preciso olhar para
dentro que precisa ser tartaruga
assim sem olhar pra dentro seguindo
apenas o fluxo do mercado nas
oportunidades externas e não das
oportunidades e inquietações internas
a gente constrói empresas cheias cheias
de faturamento mas às vezes vazias de
sentimento cheio de transações
comerciais
mas às vezes poucas transformações
sociais cheias de idéias mas poucos
ideais cheias de bens de consumo mas
pouco consumo do bem cheia de ação mas
pouca intenção por trás daquelas são
porque que ofereço isso para o mercado
qual é a minha intenção mas existe sim
uma grande geração de empreendedores a
qual eu faço parte que vem injetando
novos elementos no mercado de trabalho e
mostrando que dá para jogar esse jogo do
setor privado de uma forma diferente dá
para inventar dá pra trazer uma nova
abordagem esse mundo sabe que esses
empreendedores têm em comum uma crença e
eu construir uma teoria que disse que
existem três elementos essenciais para a
construção de um negócio com o propósito
de um negócio transformador
esses três elementos fazem parte da
trilha da transformação
o primeiro elemento é a consciência
a consciência é quando o empreendedor
entende que aquilo que ele faz afetam
todo e aquilo que o todo faz afeta o
negócio
dessa forma ele consegue sentir
interdependente e não independente do
mercado ele tem um senso de
pertencimento ele tem um senso de que
ele pertence ao universo que o negócio
dele faz precisa estar conectado com
isso a partir do momento que ele tem
essa consciência expandida ele consegue
olhar propósito e se perguntar por que
eu faço o que eu faço porque o meu
negócio existe
não que eu faço não como eu faço não as
metas mas porque ele exige com a alma
com a expressão da crença qual o sentido
qual significado ali mora o propósito
essa chama interior que vibra muito
forte no meu coração me faz levantar
todos os dias nesse sentido por trás do
que a gente faz esse é o segundo
elemento da tríade da transformação que
essa crença
nessa nova geração de empreendedores a
partir do momento que a gente tem uma
consciência expandida um propósito claro
e forte a gente consegue proteger o
elemento
que não poderia não poderia deixar de
ser as pessoas a gente chama esse
elemento de humanização pessoas antes de
processos pessoas antes de métodos
pessoas antes de metas ea partir do
momento que a empresa ela consegue
construir essa trilha de ter essa
aliança
nessa trilha de consciência propósito e
humanização ela se torna o organismo
transformador
o que isso gera que uma empresa como é
que seria um mundo onde todas as
empresas vivenciassem essa tríade
consciência expandida para o seu lope o
local no todo propósito definido e
humanização em primeiro lugar como é que
seria esse mundo um mundo feliz
o mundo com sorrisos e sabe que a maior
vantagem competitiva de uma organização
é a felicidade com colaboradores felizes
eles têm performances melhores inclusive
dão melhores resultados também como
fazer o teste ou fazer com todo mundo é
um sorriso juntos há algum tempo
percebam como muda percebam como o do
ambiente e organizações que têm essa
trilha de como base refletem esse
sorriso dentro do trabalho e aí
trabalhar realmente deixa de ser um
trabalho para ter uma ideia isso não é
apenas filosofia tá isso não é uma ideia
isso realmente são elementos que dão
resultado nas empresas hoje você tem uma
noção o livro empresas humanizadas de
haxixe souza traz de forma muito clara
que as empresas que vivenciaram esses
elementos durante os últimos 15 anos
tiveram catorze vezes mais de resultado
de performance em termos de resultados
estratégicos e financeiros também então
a trilha de não apenas gera aquele
sorriso elas vieram também resultado
financeiro e não me leve a mal eu
acredito no lucro o lucro é fundamental
sem ele a empresa não sobrevive acredito
no lucro acredita no capitalismo mas
acredito que o capitalismo pode jogar de
uma forma diferente e é isso que a
trilha de propõe a gente não precisa
mudar o sistema
a gente pode mudar a forma com que a
gente se adapta com que a gente
escorrega com ele
essa é a proposta da tríade lucro é
importante mas antes de o ser
antes vem o amor o amor é maior que o
dinheiro o ser é maior que o t
é isso que a trilha de trás e agora vou
olhar um pouco para trás para que você
entenda um pouco de como eu cheguei até
aqui quando eu perguntei pra vocês como
é que seria se a gente perguntar se para
as crianças que vocês querem mudar
quando crescer você parar pra pensar
nisso pois é eu me perguntei
não sei como se chegou até a mim mas
durante a minha infância minha
adolescência eu me perguntava o que é a
minha ea minha passagem aqui qual é o
meu legado aquilo que eu quero deixar o
mundo e ali quando criança eu era
apaixonado por futebol que é muito
apaixonado por futebol domingo a bola
rodava a bola desvia a bola na mochila
existe uma outra grande paixão que era
criar conexões que era criar é novas
formas de fazer as coisas
inovar transformar me relacionar eu
sabia que para conseguir esse lado aqui
eu tinha que estudar e para seguir a
bola eu tinha que ir para um clube de
futebol
mas aqui no brasil é impossível não dava
para seguir a carreira tipo de jogador
de futebol e de empreendedor ao mesmo
tempo então foi ali que eu recebi a
ligação mais importante da minha vida
lembro como se fosse hoje um olheiro de
uma empresa e convidando para ir para os
estados unidos jogar futebol que estudar
empreendedorismo
ou seja eu podia unir a primeira paixão
com a segunda paixão em um só caminho e
lá eu fui pro estados unidos cursarem a
graduação essa aventura nessa jornada
incrível e jogar futebol empreendendo
só que na segunda temporada e teve um
problema uma lesão na lombar correndo
durante o jogo
me lesionei sente muitas dores nas
pernas e simplesmente parei cair momento
difícil momento frustrante sim ali
comigo tinha caído um sonho que era um
sonho de jogar bola
mas aí eu me conectei com algo muito
maior porque no dia seguinte eu percebi
que nada é por acaso eu percebi que era
dentro da sala de aula que eu precisava
estar e que a lesão tinha que ter
acontecido porque foi na sala de aula
que me conectei com essa nova abordagem
ao mundo dos negócios foi lá que eu
entendi que através dos negócios
eu poderia contribuir de alguma forma
para levar a humanidade entende que o
mundo dos negócios poderia ser heróico e
que falar de negócios não não precisava
ser pejorativo não estava se algo ruim
poderia ser falar de algo muito bom de
algo transformador de algo inspirador
voltei para o brasil com esse desejo de
contribuir para essa formação desse
movimento no nosso país entende que
antes de passar essa mensagem para o
mundo eu precisava primeiro ver ela
como é que eu ia falar para as empresas
que elas tinham que ter propósito
consciência humanização senão
vivenciasse isso na prática seria um
discurso de palco e aí eu entendi que
precisa vivenciar isso antes
e foi assim que nasceu a usaria um
movimento que trabalha com moda
consciente onde nós transformamos
compras em atos de solidariedade
basicamente toda transação se transforme
um benefício para alguém situação de
vulnerabilidade social
o propósito é dar esperança e tornar o
mundo mais humano
começamos com as camisetas construídas
numa cadeia produtiva totalmente
urbanizada por grandes homens como o
maurício eo jackson lá na calçada em
salvador e para cada camiseta vendida
outra era doada
depois passamos para as mochilas
construídas a partir de material
reutilizado
vamos para as ruas pegávamos calças
jeans e tecidos levávamos isso é uma
comunidade chamada nova esperança para
mulheres lindas como meire e raimunda e
elas construíram o chivas que eram
comercializadas
ali começamos a entender que podia ver o
impacto através da moda
em uma dessas nossas entregas que
fazemos a experiência de compra
basicamente o cliente ele escreveu uma
dedicatória esta dedicatória ea junto
com uma outra camiseta levada por alguém
em situação de rua e numa dessas ações
encontramos o seu jorge morador em
situação de rua uma pessoa incrível que
quando foi receber o presente que dizia
a mensagem que a gente não apenas do
avaí entregava mas tinha um momento com
cada um deles quando foi receber sua
mensagem ea gente vai falar pra ele
sobre a força dessa mensagem amor maior
que o dinheiro que é uma das estampas
levado para o mundo ele falou o seguinte
meu filho você não precisa me falar isso
eu vivo isso a minha vida inteira é
muito claro pra mim o amor constrói o
egoísmo destrói e meu filho não deixe de
levar essa mensagem para o mundo não
deixa não desiste o mundo precisa dessa
mensagem e talvez se o mundo tivesse
essa mensagem clara talvez não estivesse
onde estou hoje
então um convite que eu tenho para te
fazer é leve essa mensagem para o mundo
e foi ali que me conectei realmente com
o propósito de vida que de alguma forma
mostrar para o mundo corporativo mundo
dos negócios que o ser bem além do t que
os valores humanos vêm antes dos valores
financeiros
levamos um pouco mais além das ações a
gente não queria ser assistencialista
apenas queremos nas necessidades básicas
também das pessoas
nos conectamos restaurantes levamos
refeições para as ruas em parcerias com
os grandes restaurantes parceiros mais
de três mil refeições levadas para
pessoas em situação de rua mais de 100
jantares nas ruas mais de 500
voluntários envolvidos pessoas que eram
que rende se tornaram voluntários e que
se conectaram com o social a partir do
próprio capitalismo só que jogar de uma
outra forma
construímos uma casa em parceria com a
ong teto onde parte de uma coleção era
toda voltada para construir essa casa
então hoje uma pessoa que não tinha casa
hoje tem por causa do capitalismo eu
volto a dizer
só que jogar de uma outra forma não
odeia o jogo joga diferente
temos também os óculos a paz a paz de
uma necessidade que vimos nas ruas de
crianças que a dificuldade de acompanhar
a escola porque não tinham o cruzeiro
ideal e criamos os óculos de madeira
feito com madeira reutilizada e para
cada óculos vendido um outro era doado
um óculos de grau
depois de uma consulta oftalmológica
para uma criança em situação de
vulnerabilidade e ali a gente não podia
dar pra ela não apenas a visão da lousa
da escola mas a visão do futuro dela a
visão do sonho dela e percebemos um
grande impacto uma grande diferença as
crianças que puderam ter acesso a um
óculos de grau por conta da educação
e aí começamos a nos conectar com
educação nesse momento a gente não tava
ainda satisfeito
a gente queria ir além a gente percebeu
que o que a gente queria era ir à raiz
do problema e juntamos 60 moradores em
situação de rua em uma conversa como
essa e perguntamos pra eles que nós
podemos fazer por vocês
será que a gente está agindo certo que
realmente vocês precisam conversas com
homens incríveis como silvano e ali a
gente entendeu que eles precisavam de
algo que era muito além daquilo que a
gente estava oferecendo e um deles o
edmilson levantou a mão e falou o
seguinte os jovens
eu queria que você agora não se
preocupar tanto comigo eu queria que
você se preocupar se com os jovens para
que eles não venham a viver aquilo que
eu vivi hoje que você oferecesse alguma
forma educação para esses jovens
e foi ali que a gente olhou para dentro
remodelou nosso modelo de negócio
entendendo que a educação era base
olhamos para as metas da onu
nos conectamos realmente com a meta
número 4 para poder partir do
capitalismo contribuir com a educação de
qualidade das pessoas e hoje a partir de
cada peça vendida
nós contribuímos diretamente para um dia
de aula de um jovem para que o jovem
tenha acesso ao ele precisa de
transporte alimentação material didático
em infraestrutura professores ea gente
atua agora diretamente financiando esses
valores em parceria com o instituto
aliança mais de 45 instituições
beneficiadas em salvador mas temos uma
boa parte da cidade com esse propósito
de levar esperança e de tornar o mundo
mais humano e criamos uma consultoria
dando palestras workshops seminários
levando essa mensagem para inspirar mais
empreendedores mais empresas a
empreenderem a partir da trilha da
transformação também e agora estamos uma
nova estrada uma nova estrada do setor
privado uma nova abordagem ao mundo dos
negócios
um novo paradigma uma mudança de era eu
queria convidar vocês estarem comigo
nessa jornada porque a partir dos
negócios podemos sim transformar uma
unidade contribui para elevar a
humanidade e para isso eu queria fazer
um questionamento
quais são os dois dias mais importantes
da sua vida
mark twain já dizia
dois dias mais importantes são os dias
em que a gente nasce e que a gente
descobre porque a gente nasceu agora
quero trazer isso para as organizações
os dois dias mais importantes de uma
empresa são quando ela nasce quando ela
descobre seu porquê
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]